[Musique]
sur une autoroute en bois sur une
autoroute en bois trois fillettes allai
au pas trois fillettes allai au pas
les autostop une une grosse voiture de
roi celui qui était dedans celui qui
était dedans leur souris ta belle dent
leur sourit ta belle dent elles était
toute jeune et lui était chargé dans
légères et courourvitu légères et
courvéu elle grimpire dans le bahu elle
grimpire dans le bahu sans peurit petite
bergère revenaz seule d'un bal
perdu
l'homme roulait comme un fou l'homme
roulait comme un fou elle lui chantait
red dou doux elle lui chantaited Dou Dou
un refrain d'enfant qui parlait de nuit
de forêt de Lou soudain lune belle lui
dit soudain lune belle lui dit je me
sens tout étourdi je me sens tout
étourdi sortons de cette autoroute par
ce panneau interdit les voici dans les
buissons les voici dans les buissons
soudain mourut leurs chansons soudain
mourut leur chansons dans la nuit de
lune pleine qui vous donne le
[Musique]
frisson tandis que l'homme veillait
tandis que l'homme veillait une fite un
crocheepied une fite un crochepied la
deuxième un coup de Pierre la troisème
l'attrapé loin de l'autoroute en bois
loin de l'autoroute en bois elle vous le
MIR en croix elle vousou le MIR en croix
tandis qu'il criait de crainte les
filles criaient de joie et puis lente
lentement et puis lente lentement
elles haut de ses vêtements elles haut
de ses vêtements voici le temps
implacable dé tours des tours des
tourments l'une frôle ses cheveux l'une
frôle ses cheveux l'autre ses lèvres en
feu l'autre célèbrees en feu la
troisième alors s' chararne sur son
ventre si soyeux et sur le loup sans
défense et sur le loup sans défense ce
fut le diable et sa danse ce fut le
diable et sa danse mais la noce de ces
gosses qui pour un soir se fiance quand
le rythme va croissant quand le rythme
va croissant et quand le lait devient
sang et quand le lait devient sang vous
racontez tout mesdames ce serait
embarrassant et puis au petit matin et
puis au petit matin dans la rosée et le
teint dans larosé et le teint il tomba
tête première sur une herbe de satin
alorser légère
alorser légère les petites fesses s'en à
l'air les petites fé sen all l'air par
les sentiers de l'enfance en chantant il
pleuv faire et la morale après tout et
la morale après tout c'est que les
grands méchants lou c'est que les grand
méchants loup doivent craindre les
bergères il y a plus de principe chez
nous et bergère il y a plus de principe
chez nous
than